ils ferment normalement ses portes à 18
heures mais à l'occasion de la nuit
européenne des musées
l'heure est à lenquête à châteauneuf sur
loire le but de ce jeu familial trouver
un objet des collections du musée à
l'aide d' indices laissés un peu partout
une manière de visiter les lieux tout en
s'amusant
j'ai du mal à la question 1 et à la
question 2 sinon bah on a moins mal et
la 3g
on n'a pas la même réponse on dit déjà
en attendant de résoudre le mystère pour
rachel les musées gratuits et ouverts le
soir c'est un bon moyen d'inciter de
nouveaux publics à les découvrir
nous les jeunes ça peut nous inciter à
un andy musée parce que longtemps
étudiants jeunes forcément les moyens
fin de l' enquête
rachel et séverin ont réussi à percer le
mystère atteignit le premier la bonne
réponse
d merci oui c'est bien vu ton c'est un
bouton beurre bah je prends une araignée
de manière uniforme entre cave de
mariniers travailler sur les matins
avoir effectivement consacré à la
navigation
le musée de châteauneuf retrace
l'histoire de la marine sur la loire les
visiteurs peuvent aussi découvrir un
nouvel espace dédié à l'écrivain et
enfant du pays
maurice genevoix